okay I everyone we are here doing a
Wilson language design review part of
our incremental language development
series and we have various uh topics
first one is Echo functions
all right temporary echoes
yeah so I thought we'd built Echo
temporary what happened to Echo
temporary did Echo temporary not make it
or
no no we never had a design for Echo
temporary and I don't know what this
thing is that Ian has you know just sort
of flipped together in an afternoon but
um you say very dismissively at I but
might be yeah well because I know that's
exactly what he did
um and and I can vouch for it being
whipped together
so okay is this in the Prototype build
yes
but but you know there are there are I
mean there was a whole constellation of
issues which is why this was never done
okay right
I mean the use case that I really could
see
is something that I just ran into it's
like I put an echo in somewhere
the the two things that that I've run
into one is I'm just spraying garbage in
my notebook by having a lot of echoing
going on and I you know I care about it
while the thing is running but once the
thing finishes it's like okay it's done
I don't even see any of this stuff
anymore that's case number one and case
number two is it's just spewing Echoes
all over the place and that's that's not
so much an echo temporary it's some kind
of echo limited type thing well although
maybe the echo temporary could be
limited
yes that's true too it could and it
could have a a scrolling window so to
speak of what it was showing you right
because basically I mean I think the use
case for Echo temporary is basically
when you want progress reporting that
you will never want to look back at once
it's done exactly
yes exactly so what are we going to see
here
I'm gonna assume this is just using
print temporary
yeah it uses print temporary and then
modifies the cell object to look right
which is a hack
okay what how does print temporary
prints and then it disappears when the I
mean if I say print temporary six and
then I say pause of one I'll see it
until it finishes right so why can't we
do the same thing with Echo
isn't the obvious thing to do to just
Echo temporary do the same as print
temporary
that's what Echo temporary is doing yeah
okay and so it's I what's the horror
story
well I mean if I mean I mean we we would
need a better implementation but I mean
if that's literally all you want I I
suppose that's something you could have
although I you know
um
I I'm
you know I'm not really convinced that
this is a particularly useful thing
because normally I wanna I I you know I
I don't want it to survive long past the
evaluation but I do want it to survive
test evaluation so I can figure out what
just happened okay so here's here's a
question here's a question
if the evaluation is a long evaluation
then you basically want it to just be
there while the evaluation is happening
if the evaluation is a short evaluation
you need to say what just happened you
know because you're confused you know
you get what I'm saying
I mean it all went by and then you don't
have um
uh and then it's all gone so to speak so
in a sense if the thing lasted
I mean if you could set a version of
print temporary where there was just a
single Little X where you press it and
it all disappeared
and that's a different type of model
where where let's say it was a thing
like the the um too big output output
where all of the all of the um Echoes
were all collected together with an X
you press the X they'll go away why not
a menu item
for what for them going delete all
Echoes from The Notebook
I don't think I'd want that
because I don't know what the I mean if
I echoed two hours ago I don't want to
lose that
I don't think that's I think more to the
point is the only difficulty with a with
a a thing where
you know where there's a sort of a a
control for those Echoes as they might
be interspersible of things
although you know if if it was the case
from a ux point of view that they all
lit up
um
uh
you know
um
together you know Sandra is commenting
it'll be nice to have an echo that only
shows the last eight or ten things yeah
that that's under the limiting Echoes
section we've got temporary Echoes
limiting Echoes and redirecting Echoes
and that's why temporary that's why Echo
temporary didn't go anywhere is this
became a very very broad discussion when
we last discussed it
okay all right
so limiting echoes
are
Dugan is commenting users might want to
clear all Echoes yeah Santa was saying
the same thing so multiple people here
have said
that
um
there's a kind of a clear Echoes type
type thing either for the whole notebook
or perhaps for a selected region
I mean is that well okay so that that
seems to be a thing I mean
it is
I mean we've now got a cell gear menu
right
actually that's a place where this could
actually go and be useful a delete all
echoes
right in a Cell gear menu for example
for this section if there was a delete
all echoes in the cell gear menu for
that section that would be something I
would use
what do other people think about this
maybe people here don't know about the
cell gear menu
anybody
is that in the cloud
um it's coming to the desktop in the
next version
it is in the cloud now yes
I want to see it though
yeah I think I've seen it in the cloud
but I haven't used it much
you know I'm not sure I would I mean I
guess the question is what cell types
would this menu would this gear item go
into and
uh
you know would I would I
really want to it to appear all the time
well look look look look look look look
here it is okay here's the here's the
this will be a perfectly reasonable
place to have a delete all Echoes under
this uh section heading for example
well you know because it's just a menu
item I mean we have a menu item for like
delete all output right I know we do I
yeah I guess so it might be
it's except that you know it wants to be
you kind of want both one for the whole
notebook and one for the selected region
well for the for the all output can you
not I don't use it much so I don't know
but can you not select a section and
then only output in that section well I
don't think so and I don't use it and
you don't use it and I you know it's
it's look it was put there well I use it
but but not in I've I've never attempted
that
um I use it to actually delete
everything in in a notebook which is
which is really quite useful
um let's see what happens if I delete it
and still have a section no it applies
globally to The Notebook it ignores the
selection yeah but it easily actually
something which maybe we could change
but yeah I wouldn't want to
have that conversation without John yeah
so the thing is though I don't I
I'm not sure exactly why
why it would be so useful to have this
delete all the Echoes if we had some
Echo temporary or Echo limited or
whatever like my my guess would be that
basically people have Echoes while
they're developing code once they you
know they fix their bug or whatever they
just want to clean up the notebook and
delete all the Echoes or something yeah
exactly well you know
to which I which I say is kind of silly
because you know my solution to that is
to you know save my corrected code and
reload it and then evaluate make the
Echoes Disappear by evaluating the
corrected version and making sure that
the bug is actually okay so it's all
right let me tell you why that doesn't
always work okay so sometimes I have
things where I had an echo in there but
it took 10 minutes to run
and then I want to delete the Echo and I
obviously I can go and do that
but it's it's annoying to have to do
that the other Echo temporary or an echo
limited would kind of just solve that
problem yes it would right but I mean
the other case that I think is more
common case is I put an echo into an
inner loop
and because I want to see roughly what's
happening in that in a loop but then the
things in the actual run it's going to
generate a hundred thousand Echoes which
I just don't want I just want to see the
beginning of that in a loop
right so and I would be okay seeing
either a just the first few or a window
or a running window of the last 10 or
something continually updated where the
thing basically is like a thing where
you know it's adding ones at the bottom
and it's deleting ones at the top right
and that's what I I called stack and
queue stack is like messages once you
hit a message so many times it doesn't
print them anymore
Q was a suggestion from Christopher that
it would have a fixed number that are on
screen and you would like lose the first
ones
yes and keep adding new ones to the
bottom right
so I actually don't see how the limiting
Echo like perhaps we want the limiting
Echoes Behavior but I don't see how it
addresses at all the problem of wanting
to clean up your notebook
IT addresses the problem that I just
described where I ideally put an echo
into a loop
right and the advantage of an echo
limited would be that I'd see the first
10 times it hit that in a loop but not
the next hundred thousand
now okay you've got things here about
rate limiting okay let's okay let's just
get everything out on the table yeah
these are not like alternative
no I know these are all distinct items
yeah I realize
how much do we care about redirecting
echoes
I've never cared about that does anybody
else care about that
I've never used it
but it doesn't exist well we did suggest
having it somehow display Echoes In
something that looks like a progress
indicator
but I don't know yes right well two two
things about that one that would be a
little bit like the echo limited but
maybe more beautiful
but second it seems like that's I mean
I don't really know the status of the
progress reporting stuff but it does
seem like that's something that we
should definitely have and I think is
supported somewhere in the progress
supporting stuff where you could have a
progress report that maybe doesn't even
have a progress indicator but but it'll
still say like what it's doing right now
right well so but that
what would that be that would be an
overall wrapper I mean that would be
something where
um
right that would require more
infrastructure
yeah but it's going to be something like
uh progress panel or something and then
it's got blah blah blah blah blah and
then it's got an echo inside it and then
the progress panel would Pick Up The
Echoes somehow I don't think you'd call
it Echo I mean presumably I again I
don't know how the progress
I don't even know what the progress of
the progress stuff is right now but I
mean
I'd imagine that there will be a bunch
of sort of progress reporting functions
where you could say something like I'm
now 10 percent done or oh I've just
finished the next iteration of my Loop
or whatever and one of those functions
would be something like you know
set progress status or progress status
of quotes you know I just finished the
blah phase or something
um yeah so I mean so status or something
like this is really the with a with an
overall wrapper but so who knows about
the progress
uh reporting infrastructure
that I thought that was your thing well
yes uh
uh but
I mean
it's
I you know there isn't sort of I mean
we've we've made no attempt to
um
I mean I guess there's a little bit of
sort of Standalone stuff which I would I
would need giulio to to remind me of all
the details right but mostly it's right
you you have your function and you you
know you you sort of Feed the progress
reporting to
uh
uh you know as as you know the data and
that sort of decides what to display
based on what the data you give it is
which can be right there can be no
estimates of anything it can just be you
know all I have is the current status
um or it can be as elaborate as the you
know classify predict progress things
but one feature of this
um
the uh
you know one nice thing about the
classify business is it gives you this
great big progress
you know indicator and then when it
finishes its job that all goes away
right and that's useful and that's
that's what we keep on saying here is
look what are our objectives you know
have the status information
disappear when the computation is
finished
yeah that's case number one and case
number two is
um
not have too much status information
appear
and I would argue that second one has
two parts one of them is just the the
aesthetic I don't want you know 100
pages of junk in my notebook the other
one is the more practical like I mean
we've had this problem forever but if
you you know if you run do a print of
whatever comma billion it will basically
crash your front end
yeah okay so protecting the note
protecting the front end and Aesthetics
and by the way I I'd like to comment on
the first one that
but but right my claim is that
you know in the progress indicator case
right none of that information see I
just see that as completely distinct
from Echo right in the progress
indicator case I don't actually care or
need to know sort of any of the details
I just really want to know you know
what's happening at this exact instant
in time and you know whether that's you
know just saying telling me what it's
doing or whether it's a a you know a
horizontal bar giving me some possibly
horribly inaccurate but better than
nothing indication of how much time
remains
um but right I I don't actually need to
know any of that so information whereas
Echo I'm putting it in because I want to
know what this thing actually is and I
need to understand that because I'm
debugging something right because often
I think Echo is is useful for like I
mean I think Echoes often
the best way at least right now to do
kind of lazy progress recording both
because right now we don't really have
good top level you know progress panel
or anything like that but also because
it's just you know if you don't feel
like putting all that infrastructure in
if you just want to know okay what
iteration of this Loop is my program
crashing on or something like that then
you use Echo
right and I think it's also useful you
know like that Echo returns its
arguments right for like the so progress
if we had something like so progress it
probably want to work like an echo where
it does that so you can just stick it in
yes for sure okay so look I can see a
couple of things we might do here so one
possibility would be
um
uh one possibility would be something
like uh and this is a bad name but Echo
panel
okay where
there's a bad name but basically what
that means is collect the Echoes from
the evaluation of expert and put them in
a temporary panel which will go away
when this Echo panel exits
well I was going to assume you were
going to go the echo limited route so
it's going to make a panel that's you
know
that has limited space okay but then I
would assume that it would based on the
I guess the name is fake but you know I
would assume that it would would keep
living
right yeah I think whether you wanted a
panel is independent from whether you
want it to be temporary you might want
it after the evaluation summary that you
can actually look at
or maybe you even want like an iframish
type thing where you can scroll through
it but it just doesn't take up too much
space in your notebook
yeah although I would argue I mean maybe
maybe there should be a way of of
getting it to do that but I would argue
that by default it should just trim
things because it doesn't you know the
front end problem right well I mean
we've we've already got some of these
things from the console output the the
um the console notebook window what the
messages window
has some of these same properties
doesn't it
uh right and you set print to have print
to the messages window or am I is that
not one of the locations no you can do
it you can do that I believe yeah I
believe you can I believe that's dollar
urgent or something you
because I think the echo action or at
least having Echo support print action
was an external report
because
you can't really it goes in your
notebook you know
right but I I would guess that that
would be solved if if we had you know
Echo related record temporary or
whatever like my guess is that the only
reason why anyone wants different Echo
actions is because they they want one of
those pieces of functionality
all right so let's again let's review
what we've got here
we've got the concept of an echo
temporary that is just like print
temporary and that basically lasts for
the duration of that uh in out
you know element
that's thing number one
seems straightforward is it useful I
don't know
but it's directly analogous to print
temporary and that's presumably what you
implemented here is that correct
yeah so this needs more work probably in
the C plus plus code to be done
correctly
okay this is basically just print
temporary okay but but Echo temporary
one question is does there need to be
scoping that is other than you know
reple level scoping
well I would argue that
nothing should be specific to Echo
temporary if-based scoping you mean rate
limiting and location
no I mean scoping as in when does it go
away the one scoping thing that we
already have is quiet echo which totally
disables Echo
right but but okay but but that's but
what I'm saying is
you know when does it go away right does
it go away
when you hit because you could imagine
something like this Echo panel thing
where it echoes Echoes Echoes while it's
running that piece of code that takes it
five minutes or something then as soon
as that piece of code is finished it
cleans up like a progress monitor it
cleans up all the Echoes from that piece
of code yeah I called that temporarily
Echo
in the agenda
okay
and I'll just say temporary Echo is the
idea for an option that you could use in
for example Echo timing all the echo
functions
oh boy
I see that's another issue is is those
functions whether how you make those
temporary
yep so is there I mean maybe the
solution because right we're running
into the the we're going to have some
giant Matrix or hypercube of
of options I mean for these things like
limited and temporary or panel or
whatever
are there cases where you're going to
want it
are there cases where you couldn't just
do it with an outside rapper that is
other cases where you're going to have a
bunch of Echoes and you want some of
them to be temporary but others not or
some of them to be in The Limited panel
and others not I don't think so I think
that's a corner case I agree with you I
think an outside rapper is interesting
and Stephen you've asked for like this
particular Echo as it appears in the
source code to only repeat so many times
which is yet another
issue yeah I know
but I mean I I think look this is very
much like error handling it's something
where
you know
if you want a very particular Behavior
you're going to have to program that
behavior the question is can we automate
doing something somewhat reasonable
much of the time
okay I mean by the time you are running
your you know
you know by the time you'll Echo
is the primary output you want from your
program and things like that then you're
playing a different game so to speak
we're primarily you know Echo for
Diagnostics and you really don't want to
think that much about the Diagnostics
you know that they're they're sort of a
temporary thing
so okay the thing that
I see so the question is if we had an
auto wrapper
um
let's say Echo limiting or something or
echo echo control
[Music]
um
we had multiple outer wrappers which do
these different things how would we feel
about that I mean because one of the
issues is you're just going to put one
echo in somewhere
and
you know I can see it being the case
that it will be useful to just be able
to say Echo temporary in one place just
because you know that's what you want or
to be able to say Echo Limited in one
place
because you know that's what you need
right because I mean also it means that
you have scope
right you can you can even say something
like suppose I have a big loop of Loops
right I could say something like you
know Echo temporary around each of the
inner Loops so that it will print a
bunch of stuff from Loop one then once
that Loop finishes it'll delete it all
and then start printing stuff for Loop
two and so on like that's a useful
Behavior I wasn't thinking actually that
was not what I was thinking of but it's
a good idea what I meant by this was
this is a One-Stop shop that just does a
temporary Echo and that's all it does
just as a shortcut without putting okay
so you're suggesting Echo block
right you could call it control but
block seemed to make sense too yes well
wait would this be a general I mean I I
was sort of imagining there'd be uh I
mean maybe this would conflict if we
also had a standalone Echo temporary or
something but I was imagining that there
would be you know you know maybe a few
different rappers for stuff like make it
limited make it temporary whatever and
you probably asked these and so on I did
the temporary thing as an option which I
called destroyed after evaluation like I
mean the favorite symbol name
look
um
is that a real thing yes for dynamic or
yeah I think dynamic or dynamic module
but not documented
um okay but but
okay I mean we want to see what this is
we definitely want something where you
can have an operator form because you
know and what I'm suggesting here is you
know the the sort of quick
one stop
version
and then the you know the wrapper
controlled version
and so in this version here you don't
get to do Echo timing temporary this is
just a pure you know along the lines of
we are just trying to make the easy
things easy and this will be just a
One-Stop shop it just does standard Echo
but is temporary and maybe this isn't
sensible but that's okay and then on the
wrapper what we would need is something
that has some kind of
um
uh well I mean we've we've already got
quiet echo which is a rapper
and
you know this is a stupid name but I'm
just saying and panel Echo
collect echo or something Echo Handler
no well but look limit Echo yeah okay so
we could have quiet Echo and limit Echo
right is this supposed to be the the
Handler for all these things together or
is this just one of them
I know but the question is are we gonna
have a unified rapper for doing things
like limiting temporary fighting maybe
even quieting or are we gonna I think we
should have wrappers several specific
rappers and perhaps a general rapper
because I think you know this is for
debugging and things like that you just
want to put the damn thing in there you
definitely don't want something where
you have options for trailing at the end
yes right which is why would argue it's
better to have multiple ones and if you
have multiple ones presumably I mean
we'll have to think about how they
interact and I'm sure they'll be a bit
of a mess there but
uh you know I'm not sure what the value
of having a general one would be because
you could always just Nest them yeah I
agree
so what does limit Echo do
it limits the number of Echoes that you
get generated from this evaluation
so it just has takes the infinite limit
of the uh of all the Echoes that you're
printing or something
never mind
no but I mean unpresumably after 10 and
then you don't get any more Echoes yeah
it's like it's very much like
um the thing that honestly has not been
bad that we invented you know 35 years
ago for for um error messages that you
you know you print three and then you
stop and then similarly here this could
print from every source of echo in the
code it could print a limited number of
times by default
so I mean how it determines that seems a
bit troubled I mean with messages it can
get around it by basically saying you
know you can only print a certain
message tag three times
I mean maybe we could do something like
but I I agree it might be good yeah yeah
I mean we could do something of just I
mean so one question is uh would you
want to limit it
even if well
right like even if the Echoes were
technically different like if it was the
same Echo but say it includes a number
and the number is slightly different
yeah I mean we could Echo it we could we
could do it based on the label as well
because because you can label Echoes
right
yes but okay but so could this just be
an optional second argument to quiet
Echo no Clyde Echo comma in
you allow the first in and then quiet
them after that
well I mean how would we do the operator
right now it's effectively zero allow no
echoes
yeah but just purely syntactically how
would we do this
you know expert comma n
no I know that but but we want to be
able to say I mean you want to be able
to say quiet Echo at sign a big piece of
code
or slash slash Squad Echo you don't want
to have to go you can do that now but it
completely quiets it no I realize that I
understand I understand what you're
suggesting at a language level I'm just
saying at a pure syntactic level it's
very inconvenient to have to say quiet
Echo and one piece of code and then
can't be an operator form anyway because
it's hold all
right
well it's whole it only needs to be
helped yes okay fair enough but I mean
it needs to hold
you could use infix
you could do tilde quiet Echo tilde at
the end I'm like a block or module I
understand I understand nobody's going
to know to do that but
I mean this could that is an interesting
you're telling us nobody's
what's that once again you're calling me
and Ian nobodies
oh that you you use infix great I love
that mechanism I just never use it
I mean it's it's certainly not an
everyday sort of thing but uh you know
every now and then it's it precisely
hits the spot
that I have never
seen either you or Ian in the
entity store so we're not entities true
okay there you are
okay but no this is not a bad idea a
quiet Echo with the number there but I
still think
okay what are the cases we're trying to
do so if limit Echo
okay and the other one would be collect
or panel echo or something
which would be the thing that collects
The Echoes into a panel
that
presumably goes away I mean what's the
point of that that one would be the one
where it has uh you know the most recent
Echoes showing up and the older ones
disappearing
whereas limit Echo would just say cut it
off
panel Echo would show a panel that is
kind of the progress panel
and
I don't know whether what the right name
for this is but this one
would
I'm not so
I mean
what we really want here
is for these Echoes to go away
when the evaluation of this thing ends
interim echo or something
it's a bad name but you know what I'm
saying so this is this is
um
uh
show The Echoes
during the evaluation of expert
and clean them afterwards
right
and this one is
uh
collect all echoes in a in a sort of
scrolling panel
and this one would be
uh cut off
off the sum number of Echoes
should we call it Echo with cleanup to
be like with cleanup
for which one for this one here interim
Echo
I'm not sure it has much to do with
cleanup honestly I mean the cleanup is
defined you don't Define the cleanup
it's predefined
I don't know well we could say clean up
Echo
because in fact this function when it
finishes will clean Up The Echoes
right
right
that's the value of that thing as a
thing which has the Echoes cleaned up
why does it even need to contain an
argument why can't it should be clean up
Echo open clones
what do you mean what would that apply
well I mean we we wouldn't need we would
need the we would need to implement a
hold all sub values in order for that to
be useful
well I I just mean you know if the idea
is to function that just I mean there's
I see okay there's one version which is
okay fine yeah it's delete all the
Echoes that occurred you know during
expert you know it could clean up all
the Echoes that were printed during the
evaluation of expert as opposed to just
clean up all Echoes right yeah
well okay so look this is
I mean
this one here is now unfortunately we
would have to have a default value of 10
or something for for this for it to be
useful although we probably could have
an operator form could we no we couldn't
have an operator form
no although I think probably a lot more
than 10 but yeah
as the default
yeah well I mean basically the default
would be a page-ish of Echoes
I mean or maybe we have to have
something where we have a
um dollar Echo limit I mean just like
just like how do we control how the two
big thing comes up how do we control
when we do range of of um dollar output
size limit
so this will be analogous to Dollar
output size limit
right and there could be an echo limit
option
if you wanted to temporarily reset it
is size a number or memory or something
um
I think uh
I think it's a byte count but I don't
remember and it's maximum bike count
yeah yeah
okay so
I think this is a pretty reasonable
proposal okay so I'm I'm suggesting that
we have
um
okay
I'm suggesting that we have
Echo temporary
I think
as a as an internal Echo just oh I'm
just just like print temporary but it
returns its argument yes
and then
that everything else is a rapper
and then Echo temporary is like saying
clean up Echo
so Echo temporary would clean up once
the
evaluation for that input line is
finished the cleanup Echo would clean up
when that when the cleanup Echo
expression has finished evaluating that
is not an input line yep that's correct
so those things are equivalent if you
just say slash slash cleanup Echo
at the end of your input
yeah
so limit Echo
would be the Echoes are going to be left
and and so
a Not Unusual thing to do would be to
say you know clean up Echo
at limit Echo
at expression
it's not terrible
because I mean the sloppy person
is just going to say limit Echo
or
and then this panel Echo limited Echoes
for protecting your front end right
what's that
limit Echo is for ensuring you don't
have a ton of but I I actually think
that we should have a global Echo limit
just in order to not have this craziness
as Sanders commented on the live stream
and I agree that just to avoid that
craziness and that would apply always or
only within limited no always because
you know but we don't need limit Echo
right what's that
limit Echo would be unneeded then no
it's not unmuted it's not unneeded that
that will be a big limit okay it's like
you're not going to generate more than
10 000 echoes
so it'll be higher than dollar Echo
limit by default yes
I mean
dollar
uh
uh Bad Name Ultimate Echo limit
um
I don't know what the right name for
that is but that's a protection like
recursion limit right like all these
other things it's a system protection
limit maybe this actually this this
maybe this gets called dollar default
Echo limit or something
I'm not sure and this would get called
Max Echo limit
yeah that suggests you can't set it
anything bigger than that I mean session
Echo limit
that suggests that it Aggregates over
the whole session
if I just asserting with them we're
going to have a supreme Echo limit and
then a number Supreme limiting Echo
limit
right
an echo limit limit
right the
um
one limit to limit them all
right
only if there are nine for for the for
them Kings of Men
what
he made a Lord of the Rings reference
one ring to rule them all oh I see I see
I see it a a
Trilogy I have not read in over half a
century I might add
and I've never read it and I couldn't
sit through the movies either so the
poorly educated
um okay look I think we've got we've
made some progress here I think we
should consult with giulio about the
panel stuff and progress monitoring
stuff but I think we've got the elements
of a plan here and I think we should
think through whether there's any you
know whether this makes sense
so I guess we
take mert to look at
well I don't know whether any of these
are going to be the the one feature of
the did you prune this by things we've
already done
yeah we pruned out the things we'd
marked as already completed and reviewed
okay
well persistent Expressions
this is an Expressions we can consider
done okay
um
that's done
system credential
it's done
uh
this is done as well
okay
inherited block
the heck is this
it's basically a shortcut for the idiom
block x equals x comma dot dot dot where
you want to only temporarily add things
rather than starting from a completely
clean slate
what
what do you mean what what is blocking
so it's it's like if if if they'll do
you know X has a value already and you
want to build on that value but then you
want to all reset once you're done
yeah so like the final example I have in
this section is say you want to overload
fractional part to work on interval for
some reason you don't want that to be a
global change but I need to do some
specific operation where I need it not
to return unevaluated I can say
you know fractional Parts I'm making
this modification to handle on interval
it only happens inside of this block
but you don't want to free the other
usages of fractional part is the point
very clear this is used all over the
place internally
so it's a it's a block that is for
that does not block that doesn't clear
the current values right normally block
clears the current definitions but
sometimes you just want to append
locally append to those definitions and
then and then revert the stack of
definitions back to where it was at the
beginning of the block exactly correct
I I see this is a useful thing I mean
I don't know whether people you know
it's a non-clearing block
but I don't know what the right name for
it is what is the right name I mean so
we have this functionality is what
you're saying
yeah internally so if we had a name we
would be golden
correct
and then an inherited block just doesn't
seem like it's the right name
uh
right I mean a pending block block
append
block upon doesn't know no because
that's that's just something different
yeah
I just don't think appending is is um
you know
um
it's like building on top of building
building up
um block with definitions that's too
cumbersome
I don't know what that means I mean it
it block
right it's block keep definitions if we
want it to be very verbose about it it's
weird because block
you know the English definition is both
like barrier and section I originally
had in mind section when we named it
right which just is still a section but
it's no longer a barrier
well in a way it is it has both meanings
but it's a blocking definition but the
door is wide open the door end is open
it's not a bearing you're not blocking
the definitions that's the whole point
of inheritance right right you're black
sorry for inheritance out right the
outdoor is closed but the indoor is open
got it yeah so yeah maybe local I mean
in some sense this could be localized
it's right yes or or
loc locally locally something
you know something that doesn't have the
word Block in the name might be
preferred yes
well what about localized
it's a localized unfortunately does
suggest that it doesn't that it keeps X
fully local like a module
yeah that's sort of the sort of
hesitation
um Extended
or extending
well there's always extending block
babies are building out whoops we can't
hear you properly
makes me think of Jenga
what's that extending black something
for Jenga the game you know with the
Tower and the one relax yes
is it actually a thing for them or is it
just a reminder of that it just reminds
me yeah
um but I think it's fine now
although it's more extending into the
past than to the Future which is kind of
well it's been extending you are
extending the definitions as opposed to
oh
I thought it was the block that was
extending if you know what I mean
no I was thinking of it it was a
um
right yeah I see I see what you mean now
you explained it but yeah it's a module
of function extensions
is or
a block that allows you to extend
existing definitions or something
well this seems like a function that's
worth having I mean are there any
semantic issues with it or is it fairly
clean
as far as I know it's clean I think the
name is the issue
you're retaining values is what you're
doing I think
then our livestream is suggesting
inherit scope
but inherit I mean we've always seen
inherent values
right
yeah
I mean yes it is a scoping construct but
how badly do we want to
emphasize that
what about inheriting block
is this related to a notion of
checkpointing like focusing on the fact
that we will remember this thing we are
about to change
what sort of what did you say was that
but I was thinking about some something
related to check pointing rather than
focusing on the fact that we are going
to block something focusing on the fact
that we will remember the definitions
for this object you are about to change
it is correct that we are doing that but
I think that that's going to just that
kind of name and will confuse people
I personally inheriting block doesn't
seem absolutely terrible to me
it's a block that inherits things
because you know inherited means you're
getting it from outside
I think inherited block is just
completely wrong because it's not what
it's doing but inheriting block
seems like it is what it's doing it's a
block that is inheriting I I agree with
that you know that that's definitely an
improvement
I I also agree with that I won't say I
really am delighted by the name but it's
definitely an improvement
let's try putting it in let's put it
into you know the Prototype build and so
on as inheriting block and see if we can
write documentation that makes sense
um
all right since we're on a roll just two
more minutes and then we should probably
wrap up
um he says
what's this one that cannot be simple
it's not simple no
let's not look at that one
um
that one there I sort of thought was
interesting is a um
you know as we build out syntax I mean
I'm not sure this maybe this is too late
but the idea is that just like you know
we started to use associations as just a
another different form of inert syntax
in addition to lists and rules and so on
the question is would it make sense to
have another inert wrapper
for representing what
whatever you feel like
well the like lists let you represent
things with a certain structure let's
say with associations
yes and I mean but rules we're using
sometimes as a just I want a pair of
things
so what it's compound used for it's just
list you just give it compound with one
two three
so I think it would have a different
sense I mean it would be something like
for instance okay in the insanity of the
modelica naming system
okay where you have you know blah.blah
that might be a use case
I mean
I think this is a different conversation
we shouldn't you shouldn't try and do
this now
um I'm a little skeptical but it also
sounds a bit like uh we already have
this with things like you know I don't
know circle plus and stuff like that yes
I know which people don't use
even though they have nice fancy
sometimes yes
all right that's a good point we could
just Define one of those things to be
the sinner rapper and start using it if
anybody actually used it
this one by the way is a simple one
which we've never really done
to have a menu item or something that
just gives you defined variables now
clearly when we're doing sophisticated
things that's going to get more and more
crazy
anybody got opinions about that
yeah I mean it also kind of reminds of I
mean there are a few use cases where
I mean I think this is what I'm going to
say is kind of a troubled concept there
are use cases where you kind of want to
be able to like preserve the stack if
you know what I mean
like say something like you know get me
a copy of the stack and I'm going to
rehydrate it later
oh boy yeah I mean this is sort of a
more consumer version of that where you
just say basically display the stack but
it doesn't have to be 100 you know
accurate right or the definitions
content I should go
um
all right we made some good progress
here I'm I'm pleased that we I think
we've got some good ideas here about
Echo and um thanks people here and on
the live stream and I gotta run off